- [Mark] All right Rylee.
Rylee, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Rylee] I am from San Diego, California.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- Yeah, I had both my parents.
It was a very like,
modern family structure
but they were both in the picture.
- [Mark] No traumatic events?
No abuse, nothing like that?
- No, my mom was more of a weekend mom,
and my dad was the full-time parent,
but nothing really traumatic,
it was pretty normal.
- [Mark] What kinda kid
were you in high school?
- I'm sorry.
- [Mark] What kinda kid
were you in high school?
- I would say a B average kid,
I was just kind of a normal kid.
I danced in high school,
I did like hip hop dance
and step team and normal upbringing,
just chill.
I had the same boyfriend
all through high school,
so I was like the "good girl".
(both laughing)
- [Mark] So you went on your own at what?
You left your parents' house at what?
- At 19.
- [Mark] Where'd you go from there?
- I actually went to school,
I actually went to college.
I went to Mesa college in San Diego,
which is a community college
and then I went to
Arizona State after that.
- [Mark] So today you're working as?
- Now, I'm in the adult industry,
I do like social media,
I do cam like, webcam,
things like that.
Most of it's all online
based, adult entertainment.
- [Mark] How'd you start in this?
- The online stuff?
- [Mark] No, just in general.
- In general I was working
just a normal corporate job
and I hated it.
I just woke up every day and
was like, "I'm miserable".
So, and I had some friends
who were in the adult industry
and it just always fascinated me.
I was always intrigued
by the adult industry.
I just asked some people,
I was really good friends with
this guy who was in the game
and I'm like,
"I want you to make me the
baddest bitch in the game."
From then on it just kind of,
it kinda just downward
spiraled from there.
- [Mark] What do you think
about sex work attracted you?
'Cause it's clearly not
for everybody, right?
- It's not for everybody,
I think it's the power behind it.
Knowing that you own
your body and it's the,
I don't know, it's the whole,
it's also the game of it,
being able to get somebody
to pay you for something
that everyone else's giving away for free.
- [Mark] Do you find
it a self esteem boost?
- It's a self-esteem boost.
It's a power trip.
It's also, the money is like this,
you know what I mean?
You get it really fast
and you're living a life
that our parents wouldn't even dream of.
- [Mark] You get addicted to
the whole lifestyle, right?
- Oh yeah, for sure.
- [Mark] Yeah, I hear that a lot.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How did you start?
You started as just a
working girl on the street?
- I actually started off as,
'cause I did massage therapy for a while,
so I actually started just
doing "happy ending massages"
and then that kinda turned into,
what else will you do?
How much more do you have?(laughs)
So it kinda just went from there
and I got into full-on
escorting at that point,
then I started posting ads
and just booking dates at that point.
- [Mark] So mostly online stuff?
- Yeah, mostly in the
beginning it was just Backpage,
I really did Backpage a lot.
- [Mark] Did you ever work the street?
- I did, but not till later,
I actually kinda did it
backwards from most girls.
- [Mark] Yeah, typically,
it would go the other way.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I actually did it later
because of some incidences that happened,
with the guy I was dealing with.
I had to be a little more low key
and I couldn't be so out there
'cause he was fighting
a federal indictment
and I started hitting the streets,
because I didn't want my
face out there as much.
So I moved to Miami for a
while when he was locked up
and I was walking the streets
of Miami getting money
and hitting bars and hitting hotels.
- [Mark] Have you been arrested before?
- Yeah.
(both laugh)
Oh, I've been arrested in Denver,
I got escorting without
a license out there
and then I got two prostitution
charges in San Diego,
but it was early on, it was
like the first six months
and I haven't been arrested since.
- [Mark] Are drugs part
of the picture for you?
- No, nothing hardcore.
I don't consider marijuana a drug,
I think alcohol is worse than that.
So I've smoked weed, but
not, I've tried some Molly,
but nothing, maybe two or
three times, that's it.
- [Mark] So you've worked with a pimp.
- I'm sorry.
- [Mark] You've worked with a pimp before?
- Yeah, I did.
My first, the first pimp I dealt with,
his name was Pimpsey, he
used to have a big name.
That was the guy I said
made me the baddest bitch
in the game and we just
kinda went from there.
We were actually really good
friends for a few months,
about six or seven months
before I decided that's
what I wanted to deal with.
I actually chose to deal with him.
27 years old and I was like--
- [Mark] You chose him rather than him,
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] he didn't trick
you into doing this?
- No, no, he was just a friend.
I just watched how he moved
and I respected his reputation,
I respected the way
that he handled himself,
so it seemed like the best move.
- [Mark] What's the attraction
for a girl to go with a pimp?
- When just like you go to college,
you have to pay for an education.
So for me it was like, I
wanted to have all the game
that he had and the only way
I was gonna really do
that in the beginning,
it was like I respected
him and I trusted him
and I just wanted everything
that he had to offer.
His mind was really
what I was buying into at that time.
- [Mark] He taught you the ins and outs,
the what to do
- Yeah
- [Mark] what not to do
- [Mark] all that stuff.
- He taught me how to post an ad,
he taught me how to talk to tricks
and how to get along with other girls,
to make my life easier too.
Just the do's and do nots
and you have to pay for that,
just like I would have
to pay for any education
or any tuition or institution
or university so...
- [Mark] Right.
And if he's a...
So you give him what part of the money?
- All of it.
- [Mark] All of it and what
you get out of it as what?
The education, the
expertise and you're also--
- All of it and the
companionship of having somebody
that you know that it's you
and him and whatever family
you have that you've built.
- [Mark] It's not like you
were left high and dry.
- Yeah, no.
- [Mark] He still takes
care of you financially
- Yeah, absolutely.
I would come home to new
clothes and new purses,
he spoiled the hell out of me.
I spoiled him, he spoiled me back.
- [Mark] Yeah, it just
seems like a lot of people
wanna make it an extreme,
you give them all your
money, you get nothing else.
- Yeah.
No, we, and we had a plan,
you know what I mean?
We knew exactly where
we were going with it
and it was all, we just
respected and had it.
It's a different type of love,
it's a different type of respect.
- [Mark] So that was an
ongoing relationship.
How long did that last
or is it still going on?
- We were, yeah.
Cause he, he went to jail about six months
after I was dealing with him.
I stayed with him, it was
about four or five years,
while he was in jail.
We went through the whole, like
federal indictment together.
He had a RICO conspiracy
that he was fighting
and so yeah, I was with him through that.
- [Mark] Looking back
at that relationship,
you don't go like, "Oh
he took advantage of me".
- No, not at all.
- [Mark] Not at all, right.
- Not at all, no.
- [Mark] Do you have kids?
- I don't, no.
- [Mark] Do you find this
lifestyle gets in the way
of romantic relationships for you?
- I think the issue with
the romantic relationship
is more just, I want to
say it's a lifestyle,
'cause some guys are into it,
but it's more me being
able to open up to men,
'cause you have so many men
that are willing to pay you so much money,
it's hard to be like doing it for free.
So it's, I would say yeah, it can be,
it can be a struggle.
- [Mark] Are you saving money?
- Yeah. Oh, for sure.
In the beginning I wasn't.
- [Mark] Yeah, but by
being a higher end girl,
you end up making
more money
- Oh yeah
when I, so I retired a little while ago,
I'm not escorting anymore,
'cause I'm doing a lot of webcam stuff,
I got up to about a
thousand dollars an hour.
It was minimum, I'm not showing
up unless you have that.
- [Mark] You're not spending it on drugs,
you're not spending it on--
- No, I'm about to buy my first house,
I drive a really nice car.
But dealing with somebody
in the beginning,
who taught me the value
of building a lifestyle,
definitely makes a difference 'cause we--
- [Mark] It's almost like the
pimps like Pimpsey or Bishop
or other high-end, more
respected pimps almost groom you,
for a better quality of life.
- Absolutely, yeah.
I would probably be worse off
if I was still working at
the cell phone company,
I wasn't saving anything there.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- 'Cause I was just getting my paycheck
and spending it on bills.
- [Mark] And are you, you're happy?
You would describe yourself--
- I'm way happier now than I ever was
- [Mark] You seem to be, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What personality
traits do you think you possess
that help you do this?
'Cause a lot of girls
couldn't do this, right?
- No, it's not for everybody.
You have to have a self-driven
attitude within yourself.
No one else, especially
with him being locked up
for so long, no one else made
me wake up in the morning
and go do what I needed to do.
So just if you had any job,
you've got your own
business, you have to get up
and you have to work at
everything you do every day.
The sun comes up, you're up
sun goes down, you're still up.
So you just, that's a big thing.
I think girls think, "Oh, I have a pussy
so someone's going to pay for it".
That's the difference
between being a $200 whore
and being a thousand dollar escort.
I think it makes a big
difference when you work
at your own, your own craft.
- [Mark] What do you think
the most misunderstood thing
about doing this kind of work,
'cause there's it ranges
from bottom of the barrel
to the top
- Yeah, it does.
- I've had both. (Mark laughs)
- Yeah, for sure you have the ones
that are doing it just
to pay for their drugs
and other ones who are
doing it for the life.
- I think one of the pimps sent me a text
and he said that she's 7,000 an hour
or 7,000 for an evening or something.
- Yeah.
'Cause that's where I was
at for the whole night.
It just, there's definitely
different levels to this shit,
but I think the biggest
misconception is that people...
Well where I'm at and my price range
and where I was dealing when I retired,
I think people think that
they're forced into it.
I think girls sometimes
take that victim role,
because it's easier for them
to deal with law enforcement
and it's better to say
somebody made me do it
than to say I'm a proud whore.
So I think being able to like own it,
I think that's the biggest
misconception that somebody
made you do this, no you're
free to leave whenever you want.
- [Mark] I'm sure there's
some Gorilla pimps
that make that difficult.
- There are definitely
some Gorilla pimps out there, for sure.
- [Mark] The pimping role it's got a--
- Yeah, just like there's--
- [Mark] a wider range of
any career I've ever seen.
- Yeah, just like the girls
you're gonna have low end girls,
you're gonna have low end guys.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What was the
worst time of your life?
- The worst time of my life?
Like during the game or just in life?
- [Mark] I mean related to
this, were there certain times
where it just got frustrating and--
- It got really frustrating
when he first got locked up,
because I had to learn a new way to do it,
to stay under the radar and not being able
to get on the phone and speak
to him the way we used to,
it used to be like, "Hey,
I'm dealing with this.
How do I move this way?",
and we would come up with
a plan of figure it out,
or I could call somebody and be like,
"This dude's not paying me".
I had to do it all on my own
and that was probably the hardest time.
- [Mark] He was in prison for how long?
- Seven years total, almost seven years.
- [Mark] So when your pimp, Pimpsey
was put in prison, was there
pressure on you to kinda
- tell on him?
- [Mark] Tell on him?
- Oh yeah, for sure.
I actually got subpoenaed
to testify against him
and mind you, this was
already three and a half years
into him being in prison
'cause it took them that
long even getting on trial.
So once we got to the trial factor, yeah
they tried to subpoena me to go testify,
they actually even tried to scare me like,
"You could be charged
with all the same things
he's charged with".
They tried to tell me the same thing
but where we come from,
where I'm from Southeast San Diego,
like we have a different
code and you just don't tell,
if you do the crime, you
do the time type of thing
and I was not gonna
snitch, sorry I chose this.
How can I put that on you?
- [Mark] So you never did?
- No, I actually had to
go out and get a lawyer
and literally tell them like,
"Hey, we're still on the
statute of limitation,
she's not testifying,
go ahead and charge her
if you have to."
I got all suited,
I literally thought that they
were gonna make me go on stand
anyways, I got all the way dressed up,
was there every day of his trial
and they're like, "It's fine,
your lawyer contacted us
so we don't really need you,
we have enough already".
I just think that's so big,
especially coming from the
neighborhood, the community,
in the game, just street
and growing up in Southeast San Diego,
that's so big as so many
people are so easily turned
and they don't realize that
the government is going to
or prosecutors are going to
try to make you say stuff
even if they don't have anything on you.
You know what I mean?
So it's like, "Eh, kiss
my ass talk to my lawyer".
You know what I mean?
I wasn't going to never would.
- [Mark] What was the
best time of your life?
- When I was able to say,
when I was able to transition from saying,
"I'm just the street $100 whore"
to being, that first time
that someone hands you
a couple thousand dollars,
that's such a high, such a rush.
When you come home with $20,000
and it's consistently happening,
that's, not gon' lie, that.
Then just knowing there
was an end date for him,
that he was coming home
'cause at one point he
was looking at life.
So knowing that he's coming home
and knowing our money's getting better
and we were gonna be
able to have this plan
when he comes out, that
was like a big thing too,
for just knowing that
we were gonna be okay.
That was probably the
happiest time during the game.
- [Mark] How do you think doing
this kind of work for your
most of your, or a lot
of, how old are you?
- I'm 34.
I started at 27.
I was much older when I got into the game.
- [Mark] Oh you started late?
- Yeah, I started late.
- [Mark] How do you think
doing this has changed you?
- I think it gave me a lot more confidence
and the greatest part is I have a family
that supports me with it.
I don't have to hide it from my family.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- My mom knows, my brothers
know, everyone knows.
- [Mark] And they're cool with it?
- Yeah, they found out when I
was working at the BunnyRanch,
it's kinda hard to hide
when you're--(laughs)
- [Mark] You worked in Reno?
- I did, I worked at, I've stripped.
I'm pretty out there
as far as social media,
I don't hide it,
'cause I'm a big believer
in if you're an adult woman
and you make this decision,
it's nobody else's choice,
it's your body.
If you feel like you wanna
charge for it, go for it
and I just want them people
to feel like they're safe,
when they make that choice.
- [Mark] Do you ever stand back
and look at your life and
just go, "Wow, this is nuts".
- I wouldn't say, "This is nuts".
It's more of all like,
"Look what you did".
- [Mark] You're proud of it.
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Rylee] Yeah, 'cause I don't
wanna follow the same things
that my parents had to,
they're still in debt,
they're still almost 60 working.
I wanna have the freedom to
do what I want, when I want
and being able to do
this, makes that possible.
- [Mark] Where do you see your life going?
Like, in the next like five years?
Do you see yourself married with kids
or do you enjoy doing this?
- I wouldn't mind.
I don't know, I guess
that would just depend on,
who I'm dealing with that
time, but I don't think kids,
I would love to have
kids, but I don't think
that I could like, with doctors and stuff
it's been said that I don't,
I'm probably not gonna have kids,
It's gonna be a battle, I'd
have to go through in vitro
and stuff like that.
So probably not kids,
I have god kids and nieces and nephews
that fill that void for me.
But yeah, I'd definitely
like to be married one day.
- [Mark] So, the technology has taken hold
with the industry and
you're now doing on cam.
- I'm doing a lot of
webcam, a lot of webcam.
- [Mark] That seems to
be the way of the future.
- Yeah and that's kinda,
'cause it's safer,
you don't have to touch anybody,
I'm making twice as much money.
So, I have the choice
that if I want to take a date, I can
but I don't have to anymore,
to like make the money.
- [Mark] You still do,
but you don't have to.
- Yeah, I don't anymore.
I've gotten to the point
where I'm pretty comfortable.
- [Mark] Oh, I see, okay.
- Yes, I don't have to,
but yeah, no most of it it's webcam,
I do like subscription based stuff.
Everything's web now it's
making it safer for the industry
and it's making it more acceptable too.
A lot of people are more
open-minded to the adult industry
because of webcam because
of porn industries
and stuff like that.
- [Mark] So you worked
on the street kind of the lower end.
- Yeah, I started off
taking a $100 for quickies.
- [Mark] So, tell me the difference
between that end of the spectrum
to the higher end, where you're
getting, making thousands.
- Trying to think like how to.
Obviously, the clientele is different,
you're dealing with a lot less problems,
when you're dealing with the higher,
you're just kind of in and out.
You're dealing with a lot
of like construction guys,
they're in they're out,
they're in they're out.
So it's a lot more traffic,
you're obviously doing a
lot more toll on your body
and stuff like that.
But it was fun,
I'm not gonna lie, it was fun.
It was fun to be like,
boom out, boom you're here
boom you're next,
to coming home every day, and
like "Look how much I made",
and we were just excited, was
going shopping on the weekends
and stuff like that, it was, it was fun.
I kinda miss it sometimes,
I miss the hustle and the bustle of it.
I had to change something
once he got locked up,
because I couldn't keep doing that
they were gonna watch
everything that we did.
- [Mark] Do you find doing
this for your career,
it affects your self esteem,
it makes you depressed
or anything like that?
- No, probably the opposite.
- [Mark] It builds confidence?
Yeah, somebody handed me
$5,000 to hang out with them,
who doesn't get a boost out of that?
There's other girls hanging
out with them all weekend
for free, I don't know.
It's definitely a power
trip, certainly for sure.
- [Mark] Alright, Rylee, thank you so much
for talking to me.
(Rylee chuckles)
- No problem.
- [Mark] Very interesting.
Thank you for all your
honesty and everything.
- Thank you.
Appreciate it.